and we're live what's up believe nation
welcome back to another AMA I've tried
to make this commitment to you guys -
every Thursday having something where
I'm asking questions they're me with you
or having a guest on board so this is
AMA number 9 in the series pump to be
here
welcome everybody who's joining there's
already a whole bunch of chatter
happening I love seeing the pre-session
chatter so leave me some questions tag
me up it's the easiest way to get my
attention and let's go we already got a
bunch of questions so I'm gonna go with
the people who left the questions early
the early bird gets the worm first up
Chris Young Evan thank you for Daly
amazing videos my question is tips for
picking the best possible people to be
in one's environment / team so I would
look at two things I would look at one
you want to be around people who build
you up who make you think who challenge
you to want to be better
who if you here's the acid test I would
run if you were if you were about to
give yourself a break you know like if
you if you were feeling tired you didn't
want to show up if you rolled out of bed
and you didn't have your full energy if
you were gonna come to the office or go
to your workplace with an excuse for not
giving your best that day and not not
legit not like you know you got into an
accident or something like you're just
you're not having a great day you're not
gonna give it a hundred percent you're
gonna let yourself off the hook the
people that you want around you are the
ones who are going to push you remind
you of what you're trying to do or
inspire you with their actions and so I
split it up between the people in your
environment versus your team both people
both groups can be inspirational for you
I think though if you're looking at your
team you need to bring it you know you
you're the leader and yes or maybe some
days where your team builds you up but
that's your job as the entrepreneur you
know if you're the leader you have to
bring it for your team you have to be
that person for them that if they're
slacking off or they're not feeling it
that you and you energize them you give
them the energy to want to keep going if
you look at other people in your
environment so whether you're looking at
a co-working space
or just just divide the cheerio maybe
the the barista at the Starbucks that
you like working at is always inspiring
to you or there's a little chalkboard at
a library that you like to work at it
always has an inspirational message you
know the things the people the
environment that build you up and make
you feel like I want to do better today
I think that's important I think it's
hard as an entrepreneur to get up every
day go and do your thing and so surround
yourself with the people and the
environment that builds you up and make
you want to do better I think is
important so that's first I think from a
team perspective you then also obviously
looking at do people match up with your
values what's your one word what are you
staying for do people online with that
do they like where you're going and of
course and do they have the skill set to
help you you know you could have
somebody who loves photography but if
you don't have room for a photographer
that's not really gonna help you don't
don't put your photographer on your your
website to code for you right just kind
of basic things but I think the
fundamental thing is coming in just
thinking I want to be around people who
make me feel energized and make me want
to give my best good question to kick us
off thank you Chris
moving on Abhishek Evan how do I
increase my self-esteem I very low
self-esteem if it's in the - I very low
self-esteem it's in - I need your help
so a couple things here you you build
confidence I think with yourself by
taking on challenges that stretch you a
little bit by setting goals for yourself
and then following through and I don't
think it's this big thing I don't think
it's about saying I want to hit a
million subscribers on YouTube where I
want to make a million dollars in my
business or whatever your big goal is I
don't think it's about just hitting that
goal and then feeling great about
yourself and then once you hit that goal
now you have high self esteem I think
it's about the daily wins I think it's
about the daily commitments to yourself
that you get up and you do a new hit and
the more you do that the more you build
self-esteem and so as an example this is
why I hate the snooze button for those
of you who are fans in my content you
know how much I hate this news button
because you've set a goal for yourself
that I'm gonna wake up at this time
and the very first thing that you do
every day is say no it's it's okay for
me not to hit my goal today and that
cascades throughout the rest of the day
now it's okay to not hit your goals
you've set for yourself more more
important than than not waking up on
time is that you've told yourself that
you set goals and you don't follow
through and so the more you can reverse
that and when you set a goal so you have
to be very careful about the goals that
you set for yourself you set a goal and
then you achieve it and that builds a
little bit more credibility and a little
bit more self-esteem and then you do it
again and every time you do it you're
building that positive bank account for
yourself with yourself so as an example
personal example yesterday I had a
terrible sleep I had like three four
hours sleep really tired just couldn't
fall asleep and when I did it was a
rough night and I woke up the next day
which was yesterday and I just told
myself I'm gonna get all my stuff done
you know that there's a there's a thing
there's a list of things that I need to
get done every day this is my morning
routine there's work that has to happen
there's there's commitments I make to
myself on my work out on my diet on on
my relationship and I told myself waking
up this is a good test today's a good
test is easy to do things it's easy to
check off your list when you have all
the time in the world and tons of energy
it's hard when you're on really low
sleep and no energy it's hard to it's
hard to get up and do it because it's so
easy to just to say you know what
tomorrow I'll be okay tomorrow we'll get
back on board tomorrow go do my workout
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow and then you
never actually do anything in the now
and so yesterday that was my challenge
yesterday I woke up and said this is
gonna be a challenging day for me three
four hours sleep is gonna be rough but
I'm gonna do it everything on my list
I'm gonna bang out and I'm gonna get
done today and this is a this is a good
test and I did and it was really really
hard I was really tired
it hit me after my team left and I
needed to get a lot of stuff done I had
my workout my trainer came over I didn't
cancel on him and and the session sucked
I was lifting like half the weight that
I'm normally able to lift I'm just
exhausted I'm physically exhausted
sitting on the bench trying to lift the
weights doing like 15 pounds instead of
30 and feeling totally exhausted but I
did it I could check it off I did my
workout today I did my breathing
exercises today I checked in with Nina
today I ate the food I supposed to eat
today you know I didn't let it go even
though it was hard and so for me what
that builds up is I'm able to do it that
builds my self-confidence that builds my
self-esteem so I set a goal for myself
here's what I'm gonna accomplish today
and then I did it and so that makes it
easier for me to do it the next day and
the next day and the next day and if I
set my goal say you know I'm gonna work
out and then I say yeah you know I'm so
tired I just can't do it today
listen everybody would understand my
trainer would understand my wife would
understand you know it's easy to tell
ourselves why we can't do it it's a
legitimate practical logical reason but
the fact that I set my goal that I was
gonna do it then I had to show up and do
him even though the result wasn't
fantastic it's not about the result it's
about keeping the commitment to myself
and that continues to build my
self-esteem so that's one that was a
long point but hopefully helpful for you
guys that's one be very careful about
the goals that you set for yourself and
then when you do do them when you set a
goal no matter how big or small do them
if your goal is to walk around the block
today walk around the block today right
even if you're exhausted you're walking
around that block and that will build
the self-esteem up the other thing that
I would suggest and I've talked about it
a lot and a little bit in the previous
answer is the environment thinking about
what gets you motivated what gets you
excited what gets you feeling bold the
physical environment the books you read
the videos you watch and planning that
into your morning routine so that you
wake up and the thing that happens that
makes you feel bold happens on a regular
basis if you do that a lot if you're if
you're around people books videos like
you you're you're sucking that in if
you're around that daily if you're
hanging around Elon Musk every day
you're gonna start thinking bigger it's
just gonna happen and now you can't you
can't you know follow him around all day
long but
by watching his videos reading his book
a little bit of that seeps into you to
then help push yourself a little bit
more so those two things hope that helps
Ashwin Evan my question is our
motivational videos really useful how to
say self-motivated throughout the long
run this is a super interesting one and
I think it's one that you need to just
identify for yourself what works for you
I don't enjoy motivational videos I
don't
it just doesn't doesn't do anything for
me it doesn't help me the person kind of
yelling at you go get it go get it or
whatever the message is just doesn't do
it for me but it does for a lot of
people and I look at it like meditating
I haven't figured out how to make it
work for me but I fundamentally believe
that it works for other people and so
for the motivation videos with anything
you want to dissect is this thing
working just do a test like watch some
videos see how much it changes you does
that lead to results for the rest of
your day and if so if that works for you
that every single day start your day
with the motivation video if it doesn't
then stop and go find the other thing
you know for me why I wrote the book the
top ten rules was I liked reading one of
these rules every day right it was one
page two rules a day I just like
starting my day being surrounded by some
of the biggest geniuses in the world
most successful entrepreneurs in the
world them sharing some of their advice
even though i I've read the book many
times now and the messages I've heard
before the repetition the repetition the
repetition every single morning to new
ideas helps me and it works for me
that's why I wrote the book and that's
why I showed it with you I mean I work
for other people you may think that's
really stupid I don't want to get up in
the morning and read a book for me
I rarely work out or I'd rather meditate
in the Sun or I'd rather give my cat a
hug like whatever the thing is it gets
it going for you that's what's most
important and so whether motivation
videos work for me or not it doesn't
matter it's what works for you and you
already know what works for you like
think back to what has caused you to
feel really bold unstoppable and seeing
confidence and just think what led to
that if it was watching a video great
then watch that video every single day
watch a different motivational video
every single day if it's reading the
book if it's joining hangouts if it's
having a coffee if it's getting out of
the house you know whatever it is do
that every single morning let's get to
more questions wow it's flying in those
are the ones who were who joined early
if you guys join early you're much more
likely to get your question answered and
if you tag me it's easy for me to see
too so let's get going
Mel Mel what's the one thing you want
people to take away from your content in
2018 hasn't changed since I started it's
not just about 2018 it's I want people
to do something with the content I think
like anybody any entrepreneur you're
making a product or service you want
your customers to get a benefit you want
them to actually execute my goals do not
align well with YouTube's goals
YouTube's goal is they want people to be
on YouTube all day long right they're
rewarding creators they're rewarding
youtubers who are creating content that
basically keeps you on YouTube all day
long I don't want you on YouTube all day
long I don't want you watching my
content all day long unless that helps
you actually be productive because I
want you to go off and do something I
would much rather you watch a video if
that's your thing if that's your jam
watch a video in the morning or in the
afternoon or lunch or all three it
doesn't matter as long as you then
taking some kind of action like you're
watching this video you've learned
something from it you're going to apply
it for the rest of your day
that's that's the biggest people right
in to say hey Evan how can I help you
you've helped me so much you know I owe
all my success to you first off like I'm
a super tiny part in any of your success
you're the one doing the work I may be
pouring a little bit of fire igniting
something but you're the one doing the
work so don't give me that much credit
and second the best thing you can do to
help me is to go off and do your thing I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential I want
I want you to go off and solve those big
challenges that are out there because I
can't solve cancer and I can't create
the next you know skateboard or whatever
the next big thing is I can't do that
you can and my goal is to give you some
tools some motivation some technologies
some advice and wisdom
that maybe touches you in a certain way
that then allows you to often build it
so the greatest gift that you could ever
give me it's a go do your thing and
watch however many videos you need to
you to get you to that point or read
however many books to get to that point
I then go and do that's what I want you
to do that be the greatest gift you can
give me in 2018 is whatever goal you set
for yourself actually accomplish it that
would fill me up so much and if you're
writing in to me like the greatest gift
is to write in to me a year later or six
months later or three months later and
say Evan I hit my goals I set a goal for
myself you know I watched your content
where there was one video or 300 and
then I hit my goals I did the work and I
hit my goals that makes me great that
makes me feel so good so please do that
next print Ave what is the advice for a
teenager who wants to be an entrepreneur
one start just go create something on
the side get some experience get out
there start building I had a bunch of
failed businesses before eventually
getting to the one that turned into a
success and I was still 19 when I
started that so at the edge of being a
teenager I guess but a whole bunch of
failed ventures and just mini ventures
stuff that made me some money had some
success but never never scaled I was
doing baseball cards when I was twelve
and thirteen years old and I loved that
and I learned a lot about negotiating
and how to run a business
while only making like 50 bucks and a
hundred bucks and 25 bucks or
negotiating with people three times my
age over five cents or 10 cents or 25
cents so I learned a lot of the skills
in a low risk situation and that kind of
helped keep me carrying forward so I
would find some way to start I would
look at people who have had success that
that you model that you want to look up
to and learn their stories
whether it's you know Steve Jobs or
Howard Schultz or Kanye or whoever it is
that you look up to I would study their
success be around it daily because if
you're parents that want to be an
entrepreneur if there's nobody in your
family it can be hard to keep that drive
or motivation going when it's not in
your environment so put it in your
environment consistently and then I
would I would try
flip it - say how can I use my age to be
an advantage this is the thing that hurt
me at the beginning of my
entrepreneurial career I used to think I
was too young I used to think nobody
would take me seriously and now I
realize that the youth is an advantage
like more than ever it actually is right
if you're doing anything with technology
or online it's so much easier to get
credibility like nobody's trusting the
50 year old to run their social media
campaigns right you have a default
built-in advantage so I've been looking
at how can I use my my age as an
advantage for me instead of a negative
let's see what we got we got a super
check coming in yawn thank you for the
love man I'm gonna go buy a gonna go buy
a coffee after this with your two euros
appreciate it what would you tell you
twenty old self what would I tell my 20
year old self I would tell my 20 year
old self to believe more believe is my
one word you know there we go I'm
wearing the right shirt today just to
believe more uh you know I had
self-confidence I believed in myself but
but not enough not enough of my
abilities I think every major
breakthrough that I've had in my
business career has been because I've
just believed that I could do something
bigger believe that I could do something
on a greater scale than I currently was
doing and so that's especially hard when
you have people around you who aren't
pushing you to do more I had an
incredibly supportive family who always
told me I could do anything I wanted who
always believed in in in what I was
doing and always tried to support but
everybody thinks I'm doing such a great
job which which is yeah great tough
tough problem for me to have right the
challenge with that is like who's
pushing you to go off and do better what
I want is a person around me saying hey
Evan you know what you're doing is great
and you're skippable so much more let's
go kick it up a gear come on and so
that's where these entrepreneurs help me
that's where when I watch content from
Steve Jobs or Oprah Winfrey or
Elon Musk granny these people it pushes
me to think
and I'm I'm coasting too much I can do
more I'm capable of more I need to go
off and hit it and so I think going back
to when I was 20 I could have used that
a 20 year old kid I was afraid that I
was too young I was afraid to get on
phone conversations to talk to people I
was afraid that people would would think
I was a fraud because I didn't have a
science background then I was selling
scientific software I was afraid of a
lot of things I was I was afraid of
telling my friends that I wasn't having
success I was afraid of them judging me
I was embarrassed that I was you know
making 300 bucks a month and I couldn't
afford to go out with them for dinner
and pizza and bowling or beer or
whatever and just not care as much about
them not care about other people's
opinions and really they would have
supported me if I just wasn't so
embarrassed for myself so just believe
more I would have told myself to believe
more and funny enough I have a feeling
if if I'm so what am I now what year is
it I'm gonna be 38 in May somewhat 37
and a half three quarters 37 three
quarters if you ask me when I'm when I'm
57 and three-quarters what advice would
I give to my 37 in 3/4 itself it would
probably be the same thing believe more
and that's an interesting exercise so
yes it's great I think I think it's
great for you guys to go through it
yourself it's great to think about what
advice you would have given your 20 year
old self but I don't look I don't look
backwards like I can't change it I'm not
going back to 1980 19 no when I was 20
was 2000 and I don't look back on that
but what's interesting is what would the
six-year-old version of yourself
tell yourself right now believe more
thank you for the super chat thank you
for the question let's get back to the
other questions if you tagged me it's a
lot easier for me to see Salima how do
you prevent financial constraints from
killing your creativity that is an
oxymoron the financial constraints is
what creates creativity
your creativity comes from constraints
because you need to find a different way
to stand you need to find a different
way to do it if you had all the money in
the world it's it's harder to be
creative if you look at the people
who've had the most success who've done
the most creative things it's always
been on a budget and one of my favorite
piece of advice from Steve Wozniak who
co-founded Apple you said stop thinking
about what you don't have and instead
start thinking about what you can do
with what you currently do have thinking
about the money you don't have will
never help you never thinking about what
you currently have and realizing that
you have an abundance of resources
around you that if you thought in the
creative way you could turn it around is
so insanely helpful it's not about your
resources it's about your
resourcefulness
I think of Oprah and she went to school
in potato bags because she couldn't
afford dresses so her grandmother would
cut up potato bag and sew them into
dresses and imagine like how much she
had to go and get hate at school and
made fun of and she went from there to
becoming one of the most powerful
successful wealthiest people in the
world how did she do that through
creativity and if so she can go from
where she was at to where she is what's
your Excuse that's what I tell myself
like everybody watching this just just
the fact that you have an internet
connection a computer the the
willingness to learn you're already
ahead of most of the world so what are
you gonna do about it you have more
resources and more resourcefulness right
now than most people in the world so
recognize that leverage it and go do
your thing
next Noor I'm productive and moving
forward during the holiday but school
kicks in everything collapses from help
the business and I don't even intend to
get a job with requiring a degree what
do I do
so you know I think education in terms
of a formal education is a great back-up
plan
it's one a great potential way to meet
people build your network as you know as
people are getting older and grow into
jobs those could be potential allies for
you customer
for you partners for you and having an
education is a good backup plan it's
really hard to get a job if that ever
becomes part of your path to only have a
high school degree as an example be a
high school dropout it's not impossible
but just really difficult
I think it's slowly changing I think the
education degree or the school name
carries a lot less meaning than it used
to but it's still a reality until until
like our generation is making all of
these decisions were the people who go
through the education system and realize
you know what that she wasn't that
helpful they're the ones hiring then
that's when it really starts to shift if
if you never want to get a job then
that's when I would really question
being in school and if you are certain
it's hard to know I think that's the
fact if I think back to myself you know
I never really had a job but I still
want University but I don't know that if
at 19 when I started University I could
say that for the rest of my life I never
want to have a job I don't know I could
do that and so I don't regret that I
went to my University what I do it all
over again if I was 19 now I don't know
I feel like I still would I like having
a plan I like having a backup option
unless I already had my business growing
you know if I if I started over now and
I started doing my baseball cards and
other ventures and to be more
opportunities now for 12 or 13 year old
maybe by the time I hit 19
I'm already self-made you know I don't
even have to worry about having a job I
know what I want to do so I think it
just depends on where you're at don't
run away from something just because
it's hard
I like having plans I like having a
back-up plan a plan B just in case I
don't know that I'd have enough
self-awareness to be able to say this is
what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life but if you do then that's when you
make your decision and have to live with
the consequences you know your parents
might not support you you might get
kicked out of the house right
you have to go find your way of
surviving and living you have to live
with the consequences it's not your
parents fault they kick you out
it's your fault you made that choice so
you have to live with it
umar can you give me some tips on how to
stop procrastinating so one that comes
down to having goals that are meaningful
i don't believe the people are just
procrastinators in general cuz you have
had in your past goals that were
motivating for you meaningful for you
and you work harder there's been days
that you have worked incredibly hard on
accomplishing something and you felt
genuinely proud and amazing because you
did it and so if you're procrastinating
right now i would look at your goals and
see how much of these things actually
are meaningful to me and if you're doing
work that you hate you can only do that
for so long before you your gonna
procrastinate and you're going to slack
off you're gonna not want to do it and
if you switch to something else
you could be a lot more productive so
that's one two again two previous vice
i've been looking at what's my schedule
and routine look like how do i design my
day so that every morning I'm waking up
what's the thing that triggers you to
want to play a bigger game and be bold
and confident what does that trigger for
you and put that into your morning
routine those two things more important
goals and a better morning routine and
environment to force you to take action
so make you want to take action on a
daily basis next Jay what's the most
important family or changing the world
like Elon Musk who's not really good on
family sides what is more important
family or change in the world like Elon
Musk's was not really good on the family
side got it personal preference you know
I look at Steve Jobs and he was not the
greatest father you know he disowned his
daughter and said I am NOT your father
and you know disagreed with the
paternity test and all that and I think
when you're looking up to different
people the point of that is to be able
to pull something from each person to
help you be better so I like to pull the
visionary stuff from Steve Jobs and not
the Parenthood stuff from Steve Jobs you
know my son is here my wife is here
they're important to me I think you need
to I don't think there's one right
answer you did the answer is the one you
need to figure for yourself what does
that balance look like for
everything comes at an opportunity cost
just as if you're spending time with
your family you're not spending time
doing something else and no matter how
smart you're working and how you use
your time as effectively as possible it
still as an opportunity cost and when
you're spending time on your business
you're not spending time with your
family and so you need to figure out
what that looks like for you for me I
have a general schedule that combines
both that that works that works for me
that works or my family
some people would come into it and say
well you spend too much time with your
your with your wife and your son and
others would look like and say well
you're not spending nearly enough time
with your wife and son that works for me
my schedule works for me and it's a
constant balance in talking with my son
talking with my wife and figuring out
what that looks like
that being said there are also times
where when I get really in the zone on
something I have to go all in on it
and so as an example finishing this book
it took me about six months to write
half of this book and then about four
days or five days to write the second
half the second half came because I was
on my cruise ship I was on a family
cruise ship right like it's vacation
time and my first book had come out
December 6 and I wanted I just came with
the idea that December 6 I want my
second book to come out on the
anniversary I want my second book to
come out and I just decided and I had
that look at my eye my wife recognized
it and it was very supportive and and it
meant that I had to spend a lot of time
on the cruise ship writing the book and
so while my wife was sleeping I was
writing while she was working out I was
writing well she was doing something
else I was writing and I finished the
book at least the first draft right
which was my goal and I was able to do
that because I had enough emotional
equity in my bank account with her right
not the financial bank account but the
emotional bank account because I'd done
enough because we had spent so much time
together during the entire year during
our regular monthly weekly schedule that
she knew that
getting this thing done was important to
me and that it that we go back to normal
after that sprint if on the other hand I
was neglecting and ignoring her the
entire year and our schedules were
totally out of whack that might have
been a huge problem then I wouldn't have
been able to finish my book and so I
think it's it I don't have the answer to
tell you to say hey 80% of your time on
work and 20% of the time with your
family or 50/50 or 2080 the other way
you need to figure out what's important
to you the very first thing I did when I
when I bought China dine salsa the
company I invested in here and hired
Alex to run is that's an evening
business most people who are taking
salsa classes they they do it in the
evenings nobody's gonna come at Monday
at 3 o'clock to take a dance class and
so a lot of the work would have to be
done in the evenings and so I sat down
with my wife and I said what does our
schedule look like so that we can be
happy so that my business can be
successful and that this new company
that I'm acquiring can also be
successful how many days a week what
does that look like and we planned
together the schedule so that I had time
to go to TDS when needed I time to do
this work when needed and I had time
with her as well and so involving other
people in that conversation and for you
making up your mind of how you want to
split your time and feeling good about
it don't be resentful don't don't be
with your wife or with your family and
saying oh I have to spend this time with
my wife like you you you have to buy
into it it's got to be a good balance
for you and trial and error until you
get to that balance that you think
really works and then stick to it Bryan
Amir how does develop an insane work
ethic my company is growing faster than
me so I need to develop it ASAP thank
you in advance so a couple things there
one if your company is scaling
understand that your grid is resource is
gonna be people and so if you're
building a team that's the best way to
scale because you can't do everything
and so as soon as possible when you're
making money you want to figure out how
can I hire somebody who's better at one
of these things that I'm not so good at
that I'm doing right
that I can delegate to them to do and
they love it so I can focus on being
more of the CEO and do the work that I
can be world-class at if I look at what
I do now my youtube channel no matter
how hard I worked right no matter how
hard I work on my You Tube channel if
I'm working 24 hours a day there's not
enough time in the day for me to make
all this content like to make three
videos a day and respond to comments and
research and be in front of the camera
and edit and all that stuff like it just
it's not physically possible even just
responding to the comments so I have two
people on my team that help me respond
the comments and they put their name at
the end and they save the comments that
I need to see just responding to the
comments would be a full-time day for me
because of how many comments we get if
that was if it's important for me to
answer comments then that would be a
full-time job and that that means I
can't scale right and so if your company
is growing first off congratulations
that's awesome and if you can't handle
it yourself quite often the answer is
not to work more but to bring on people
underneath you and so I'd be immediately
looking at what are your skillsets what
is important to the business but that
you are not world-class at and have no
interest in becoming world-class at and
then go find the person to do that role
for you so you can keep doing the other
things aside from that working hard is
still important right having it having a
work ethic is is extremely important and
I think the game that comes down to
solving the procrastination issue have
important goals that mean something to
you and create an environment that
motivates you on a daily basis habits
it's that your physical habits that set
you up for success every single day so
that you're off giving your best on a
daily basis
Remzi 3 3 3 Evan what's your best advice
for teenagers becoming entrepreneurs
answer that question go back about I
don't know 10 or 15 minutes you'll see
it on the replay
Joanne if 2 people will apply to your
organization one is smart but not
adventurous and the other it's venturous
but not smart who would you hire so I
think it depends on what you need in the
business I think first off what you need
to hire for is values and so are you an
adventuress company do you do you need
people to be adventurous as out of value
that you you espouse so for me it's
believed right it's my one word you can
pick up the book if you don't know what
yours is and that's where you start
because if I don't care if you're the
smartest person or the most talented
person in the world if you don't believe
in the mission that we're on if you
don't like the message of believe
doesn't have to be your one word but
somewhere close then we're not gonna fit
like you you're not gonna be a good
person for our team you're not gonna be
happy and I'm not gonna be happy and
same thing with clients I've had to turn
down so many clients who would pay lots
of money but they don't get the mission
they're not on board with it they don't
we don't have the same values and that's
awesome like let's figure that out right
away because I think too many people
just look at skillsets they just look at
okay I need a website developer so I'm
gonna just hire somebody who has the
skills for me to do it without
evaluating does this person share
similar values to me it's like getting
into a marriage and only looking at
somebody on paper and not realizing that
it's not just about what boxes they take
it's about how well you guys actually
connect with each other I think the
thing that keeps relationships together
that keeps whether it's a marriage
whether it's employees whether it's
partners is shared values and so you
need to suss that out and so that would
be where I would start values and then
it would jump down to skill sets and so
if you're looking at adventures they're
so smart
depends what I'm what are you hiring for
you know if you're if you're hiring an
accountant do you want an adventurous
accountant or a smart accountant you
know if you're hiring a a tour guide you
want an adventurous tour guide or a
smart tour guide right so start with
values think it down the skills for that
job
Pranav how do I get the idea of hashtag
BTA and belief nation how do I get the
idea of hashtag beteen believe nation so
if you're asking how I got it instead of
how you can get it
bt hashtag vta was just something that I
wanted to I wanted people to get into
the routine because I think so BT first
of all as believers taking action the
ideas come to a video every day leave a
comment on it
and how'd that start your day because
whatever the first thing is that you do
every day that becomes the lightning rod
for success ongoing so if you wake up
and you set a goal that I'm gonna go
watch your video and leave hashtag BTA
and then you do it you're much more
likely to follow through and everything
else just like making a bed making the
bed is not that important but you
believe in that you are the kind of
person who makes the bed is important so
then you'll go off and do the other
things if you have a chain of habits
whatever the first thing is in that
chain is important so make sure you do
that well will almost make sure that you
do everything else or if you miss the
first thing in the chain you're unlikely
to follow through and everything else
right if you have a diet goal
you're not gonna if you cheat on your
diet then you're also not gonna work out
you're also not gonna you know call that
person back you're also not gonna follow
through on the goals you set for
yourself it just happened so I wanted to
create something that the first habit
was really important how you can come up
with it for yourself I think it's just
figuring out what is important to you
that that started because I felt like
people were letting themselves down on
their habits I think you can have the
greatest ideas I think a lot of you guys
have fantastic ideas I think a lot of
you have plans that you know can work
and that you are seeing other people do
but you're not just you're not doing the
action your habits don't match you have
visions but you're your schedule and
your habits do not map to you
accomplishing your goals so you're stuck
in this dream world of here's what I
want to do but you're never taking the
right action and so that came out of
frustration for me I wanted you to take
the habits necessary to go off and
accomplish the success you're after and
so you don't need to come up with your
own hashtag BTA you got to figure out
what is it that you care about for
yourself and for your customers and then
how can you create an idea a product the
campaign or service around it Muhammad
Ali Mohammed Ali's in the chat which
book would you suggest for an 18 year
old who wants to be an entrepreneur a
lot a lot a lot of teenagers want to be
entrepreneurs again go back look at the
advice I gave in terms of a book I
probably wouldn't I would recommend
videos because I would rather watch a
video than look at a book
I had to pick one video let's pick one
video I would say I would say whoever
you look up to the most to be honest
because who I look up to doesn't matter
as much as who you look up to if you
love Kanye West like go watch the top 10
Kanye West if you love jobs go watch the
top 10 jobs you love Oprah etc so figure
out who it is that you love the most who
you look up to the most and then watch
the video that inspires you the most and
gets you taking action Landon
how does one figure out what to do with
his or her life I'm torn between art and
graphic design and programming honestly
Landon I think the the best comes when
you can combine them I think that's your
whitespace the genius at the end stop
thinking about this or this figure out
how to do both that's what you win
because no matter what you pick if you
just pick what were the two where is it
art graphic design if you pick art and
graphic design you'll still have this
whole feel like I want to I want to like
that programming thing it'll be pulling
at you because you feel you're stuck and
same thing the other way if you're only
doing programming you'll feel like
you're not as creative you're not doing
the artwork you want to be more in the
design business to is always going to
this hole and so the answer is mix be
the person who does the mix because
there's tons of programmers and the
people who are only programming and who
love that will crush you and there's
tons of art and graphic designers and
again the people who love that that's
their everything they will crush you too
so you're always gonna be a second rate
of either but you can be the first rate
of the mix so that's the opportunity for
you how can you mix graphic design and
programming and instead of looking at
the aura so start asking yourself that
question and once you start getting some
answers
I'm excited if you made that's where
you're gonna win prin am who is the
person who motivated you the most
I start with my parents they're on my
wall behind me they taught me to believe
in myself
they taught me I'm Everett was really
Carmichael I could do anything I want in
the world they gave me my value system
they they continue to motivate me I mean
I don't I don't talk to them every day I
don't you know they don't push me to say
Evan you should be doing
or but I they're the middle picture in
my office
for a reason apart from that I think I
think there's no one person I think is
too collective you know I make my
channels selfish is for myself because I
learn from all the videos that I put up
and if I don't learn from a video I
don't post it there's been a few that
even last week I cut because it just
wasn't good enough I didn't learn enough
from it at that point we need to cut you
need to find something else it's not
good enough and if I'm not learning from
what we're not gonna put it up and so
that collective I like learning
different bits from different people I
think it's because I hopefully this is
for you guys too there's no one person I
want to be like I want to be like Steve
Jobs in a visionary perspective but not
as a family man right and so I want to
be like different people but just pull
one piece of them that is uniquely me
and so my parents number one and then
everybody that I featured on my channel
number two Salima what's the most
important online business skill to be
successful I think just a willingness to
learn I think any skill you can pick up
super quickly if you're passionate about
it and just a willingness to learn I
think this is where I think this is what
really kills so many people so many
people who have had a little bit of
success in any field but especially the
online field they have some success in
and then they complain when things start
to change
right it happened with YouTube and then
YouTube algorithm every time there's a
YouTube algorithm that comes out people
complain and look at who's complaining
the people who are complaining are the
ones who had success under the old
algorithm look at what just happened
recently with Facebook with them
updating their algorithm for their news
feeds everybody was complaining of the
people who had success the way the old
algorithm worked and they're not willing
to learn how the new algorithm is gonna
work but this is business this is what
how every industry changes the only
thing constant is change it will
continually change and so the way that
you win especially in an online business
kind of world is that you're on top of
the new change every time the algorithm
changes
for me from me in a YouTube perspective
anytime the algorithm changes and I see
the people who have three four five six
times my subscribers they're complaining
I love it I love it
you guys keep complaining about the
changes that are making I'm gonna figure
out the new changes I'm gonna start to
crush you right I'm gonna win every time
there's a new change that means it's an
opportunity for you to win because the
people who are tied to the old rules
they're gonna keep doing it that way or
they're gonna give up they're gonna sit
there procrastinate complain meanwhile
you're hustling and winning and so this
whole Facebook thing that just happened
that's a chance for you to win go figure
it out well everybody else is
complaining and upset about it go figure
it out and win every change is amazing
and learn to to adopt that mindset shift
because a YouTube algorithm shift hurts
me right I'm a big channel now big
channel I've a million subscribers
that's a big channel so a tweak like
that impacts my channel negatively but
if I can figure it out then I'm gonna
win even harder and so I've adopted the
mindset and this is this is this has
been in me for a while but anytime
there's a change it's good it's good
this is my chance yes the people ahead
of me are gonna lose this is my chance
to win every time there's a change so
get excited about change
matvey I'm extremely impressed by your
videos it's my hashtag BTA I love it I'm
a dead junkie how do you find and create
your content without copyright issues I
want to start making videos just depends
depends on on who you're looking at
working with for the videos so example
guy wrote to me on Twitter yesterday he
said hey can you do a Jim Rohn top ten I
would love to do Jim Rohn he's if you
don't know Jim Rohn was the the mentor
for Tony Robbins and a bunch of other
people considered like the father of
personal development but we haven't
gotten permission from Jim Rowan's
people to to use content on him and so
we haven't made a video and honestly
it's it's to his own disservice not just
me but anybody else's who knows Jim Rohn
now like Jim Rohn has such great content
and he should be all over social me
yeah his message but it's not and he's
gonna fade fade into dust because
nobody's spreading it and because his
team isn't letting people spread it so
they haven't to the point in the last
question continue to learn they're
working under old rules that Jim Rohn is
a is an older while he's passed on but
the model he's using is under the old
rules and he's gonna lose and then guys
person development people who are on the
way up with with a far inferior message
who or maybe who just rip off everything
drum roll said and used it as their own
will beat Jim Rohn because they
understand the new rules because they're
willing to learn and so if you're
looking at creating content you and
you're using other people's stuff you
have to just figure out who's willing to
work with you on it or not let's see -
please answer Evan I'm from India my
product is great my mentors are
suggesting me to take a soft loan 6%
interest rate and waiver for the first
year I guess is wondering should I take
it so I hate taking money until I'm
making money so if I was in your
situation money is great to explain
something that's working as soon as
you're making money put it back into
your business 6% is not a high interest
rate are you making that like do you
know you're gonna make that back so
usually for marketing initiatives or for
growth it's worth it for Rd for
investment you don't know it's a it's a
bigger risk so when I was back my
venture capital days if somebody's
raising money for R&D like forget it no
VC is gonna want to touch you but if you
want to raise money for marketing for
expansion show me that it worked in one
market and let's go now take on a bigger
market that's logical it makes sense if
I look at what I'm doing in my channel
right showing that the first person I
hired was an editor and that guy worked
for me part time and then eventually
full time I was able to move him from
part-time to full-time because as he
took on more work my business made more
money and as he became full-time it made
even more money then I could hire
another editor right and so you know
that it's gonna work
if you don't know you don't have it done
yet you don't have any momentum you
don't have the traction yet you're still
in start-up mode
I wouldn't take on alone it's not worth
it you can find other ways be
resourceful so it just depends on your
situation if it's if it's expansion
capital then yes if it's not then No uh
Sidharth what is your best asset what's
your best asset my best asset I think is
my mindset my best asset is my mindset I
see negatives as positives I see the
opportunity and everything I believe in
myself I think the mindset I think I
could very easily have gone a different
path if I didn't have this mindset and I
think that's where most people go I
think most of the work that I do is
around trying to change people's
mindsets in a positive direction because
when you figure that out that's when you
start really getting a lot of traction
for your business print app I just read
your book your one word it's amazing
thank you for the loud print Ave
I really appreciate that make sure you
email in your receipt so you get the
bonuses the one mistake regret that I
make made for that compared to the
second book is the call to action to get
the bonuses because we made all these
bonuses for both books is a bunch of
bonuses and most people never found them
in the one word because it wasn't clear
enough where I'm fixed that for the
second book like the first page do you
want free bonuses email your receipt
here and we'll send them to you for free
but for the one word it's it's super
buried so you know lessons learned in
the book publishing world you can't you
can't edit it you know now it's out I
can't edit it so print out thank you so
much and God you enjoyed it email in
your receipt
Abhishek Evan hello Evan what are the
five things that you wish to accomplish
in life but not yet accomplished
I don't think that way I just don't
think that way for me as soon as I set a
goal for myself I start just
accomplishing it so I don't have a
5-year plan I have a I have a lifetime
plan I want to solve the world's biggest
problem I'm tattooin potential but I'm
never gonna get there it's not possible
it's a slice a lifelong plan like when
is human potential ever fully reached
and then I have short-term plans so
right now I'm building my YouTube
channel I'm investing into businesses
I'm promoting the books I don't have
anything in between you know if you ask
me five years ago where where would I be
I would not say that I would have two
books out I would not say that I have a
million subscribers on YouTube I just
have a different vision for myself a
different short-term vision but part of
what I believe in is constantly learning
they've all been changing self-awareness
understanding yourself like YouTube
played really well with what I was
interested in the books played really
well with the messages that I wanted to
get out and so I changed it I changed my
path and I'm I'm I'm super unafraid to
go in a totally new direction if my
heart is set on it so if I decided
tomorrow that you know what YouTube I
don't I don't like it it's not my
passion anymore I what I really want to
do is build buses like buses
I just love sitting in a big bus and I
want to be the world's biggest bus
manufacturer then I would close my
youtube channel down and start building
buses I would find a way maybe I sell
the channel to somebody else if there's
you know if you've built something up
and there's an opportunity to monetize
it by selling it great or or you just
let it die but you will never do great
work if you're doing things that you
don't love the day I stopped loving you
two was the day I quit YouTube when I go
off to something else buses so I don't I
don't think if I had five things that I
wish I had accomplished I would I would
be working on them right now
and so I don't so thank you for the
question
Angela Evan that's a lot of roses angel
put like seven roses and I just recently
decided that I grew out of my most most
of my friendships how do I meet other
successful entrepreneurs to connect with
listen angel that's that's a that's a
harsh and very real situation I think a
lot of people go through I think a lot
of people lose contact with their
friends in high school University
growing up you just go in different
paths you don't connect anymore and one
listen this is good this is that this is
shedding the skin this is growth this is
amazing the caterpillar has to gather
the cocoon to become the butterfly now
your butterfly congratulations
a lot of people never break free of that
so one it's sad but it's also a good
thing like yes you've lost all your
caterpillar friends but now your
butterfly right that's how I see it and
so then once you've eliminated those
people from your life whether if they're
just negative people or just you don't
connect anymore that's fine now you need
to find butterflies to fly with and I
think there's different ways to do it I
think for me I get I get a lot of love
and a lot of I get filled up a lot by
you guys by just being a part of this
community by doing this am a like why am
I doing this am a it's not gonna be a
high-performing video on my channel
compared to doing other content but I
just I want to be here for you I like
seeing the questions I want to help so
you could be evolved in in an online
community you can get involved in
offline communities you can look at
events meetups conferences organizations
you can be a part of you can look at
volunteering with different
organizations different companies that
have a mission that you really believe
in it's just it's just trying it's just
saying yes it's just getting out there
there is no perfect plan it's just
trying it you're not gonna find the
perfect plan sitting on your couch so
it's saying yes to thousand different
things and then seeing the one that
resonates the most with you in the type
of relationships that you're trying to
build do you want like one bestie then
that's that's it and then you're good or
do you want to have you know 100 loose
connections that you're still in touch
with and you're helping each other out
with figuring that out and then just
take an action it's really not that
difficult it's just taking the first
step so say
yes to everything be more involved in
this community go to the online events
that are happening go to events in your
city we need to travel a little bit to
get outside to other ones volunteer just
say yeah say yeah I say I say yes make
it your make it your goal make it your
goal that every week you're gonna do
something to try to build new
friendships and relationships every week
you have to do something and if you just
ask yourself that question what can I do
this week to try to find a new friend or
relationship answers will come you ask
the right questions you get the right
answers good luck it's exciting I'm
excited for you to find your butterflies
Alex why are we ready almost at an hour
it's crazy hello Evan I have a I have a
huge doubt I have two words I can't
bring it to just one they are love and
believe can you help out I already read
your book it's great
thank you for the love Alex two things
one I have literally on my team she's my
one word coach she normally charges a
hundred bucks an hour messaged me after
this I'm gonna set up a free one-hour
session with you to talk through some of
these things and get more clarity
because I like that you're joining in
here and I want to make sure you're
getting help my quick two cents here one
look at does one supersede the other is
one more important than the other if you
had to you know if you had to look this
one like fall underneath the other is
love a part of believers believe a part
of love just see like it's one the child
of the other and when the parent of the
other and if know if their two siblings
like they're equal they're both siblings
and look is there another word that's
the parent that's both of those so as an
example my father went through this
trying to figure out what his one word
was and he had he had adventure and he
had I figured the other one was like
niceness he's a super nice person but he
also likes taking adventure it's like
wow those two seem totally not opposite
but they're not related and what he came
up with was heart is above the two so
heart is the like adventure like heart
racing heart pumping things but also
heart in terms of being nice and caring
and compassionate to other people so
look if one is a parent of the other if
not recognize that they're siblings and
that there is a parent above the two of
them and message me about Lily
and we'll set it up next dbo how to say
no without hurting someone 1 you know
just with compassion just putting
yourself in their shoes understanding
why they're asking understanding what
they're looking for and just being as
compassionate as possible
- I'd also be looking at just making
sure that you do say no because if you
don't you're not living your life
right if you're saying yes to something
that you want to say no - that's again
the training training yourself the
mindset the daily work the self esteem
and self confidence if you're doing
things you want to say no - but you're
saying yes - you're gonna continue to
wear down your own self-confidence and
your own abilities and beliefs in
yourself and so you need to say no but
just do it as in a compassionate and as
nice a way as possible I would try to
find something that's good and that's
positive in the situation in them and
that person so they don't necessarily
take it personally your goal is for them
not to take it personally for them to
feel bad about themselves because you
said no so finding some way to lift them
up and encourage them and give them
compliments that are genuine that you
actually you know believe in but at the
same time not just saying yes because
you feel bad or guilty if you really
want to say no pronoun I'm confused in
two words why and how can I can I can
you I help me out I'm confused in two
words why and how I don't understand
your question if you can clarify on the
next one seen on tips for 2018 getting
customers to a physical storefront uh so
if you have a physical storefront I
guess also thinking do you sell products
or service so I have a physical
storefront with trying to dance salsa
the number one place that we get our
customers from is still word of mouth it
still referrals I've been looking at how
do I provide such an amazing experience
that the people who are coming in that
they're not just leaving with a product
or service they're not just solving the
need that they came in with but they're
there if they feel different there are
better human being because they left
your store that's
your goal that be the number one thing
I've been looking at what is my goal to
make this person a better human being
because they came into contact with my
store with my team with my products and
services so yes you're solving a problem
that came in four plus plus plus plus
plus once you start doing that then I'd
be looking at what kind of campaigns can
you launch especially in the social
media online world that helps people
feel that so with with TDS my retail
front it's about family one word is
family people who come in feel like
you're part of the family yes they come
to learn how to dance salsa but what we
give them is connection we give them a
family we give them friends we give them
people that they can have conversations
with and develop relationships with
which is so much more valuable than just
learning how to do a few dance moves and
then once we perfected that experience
now we bring it to online you bring it
to the website if you go to the website
Chyna dance also you'll see this huge
picture at the top about joining our
family not about we will teach you how
to dance salsa social media campaigns
YouTube videos all that kind of stuff
but the marketing won't save you if your
product or service sucks and I don't
want to say that your product or service
sucks but is it delivering the WoW are
they leaving your store a better human
being than when they came in just like
you as an entrepreneur you want to leave
the world a better place than when you
came in do that on the micro every
single day with every single customer
and by the way guys it's not just a
storefront like when you watch one of my
videos I want you to be a better human
being because of it and if you are
you'll watch more and you'll share it
and tell your friends about it
same thing for your product your service
whatever it is by interacting with you
by by connecting with you on social on
email coming into your store any kind of
connection with you means I'm going to
become a better human being because of
it you're not just gonna solve my
problem you're gonna change my life take
that as your goal your business will
grow guys it's been an hour it's crazy
it's crazy it really has not felt like
an hour for me I really enjoy spending
this time with you I hope it added value
I'm committed to doing this again next
week we'll be back I think I have a
guest on next week but either answering
questions for you or bringing a guest on
I want to keep this tradition going
because I'm really enjoying it and
hopefully bringing value to
it's it's 12 o'clock for me Eastern
there's still a huge chunk of the day
left so I've given you anything from
this if you felt motivated or got some
ideas from the questions and answers
here my sincere wish is that you take
that energy and pour it in this making
something amazing today even if it's
almost midnight you got an hour left in
the day you still have an hour left to
do something awesome do something today
that your grandkids are gonna want to
see that you will be proud to show your
grandkids make that your goal whatever
you're gonna do today with whatever's
left of today you want to show your
grandkids good luck guys I believe in
you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon